ich möchte heute abend an die
einrichtungs bezogen im pflicht erinnern
es ist meine herzensangelegenheit weil
ich finde wir diskutieren darüber viel
zu wenig in den medien lassen sie uns
dafür einmal ein gedankenspiel machen
stellen sie sich vor dass sie nach
jahrelanger kräfte sie eine ausbildung
in etlichen berufsjahren wird sich nicht
mehr arbeiten dürfen sie schauen
hektischen die medien die jetzt aktuelle
stand ist wie lange dürfen sie im beruf
noch ausüben so ergeht es in deutschland
nicht nur den pflegern die einrichtungs
bezogen im pflicht sieht seit mitte märz
vor dass alle beschäftigten etwa in
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen und
arztpraxen eine doppelte impfung gegen
kuwait 19 vorweisen müssen das gilt auch
für medizinstudenten wo sich sehr viel
an uns gewandt haben erst oktober wird
die regelung auf drei impfungen
verschärft liegt ein mitarbeiter dem
gesundheitsamt kein entsprechenden
nachweis vor kann ein betretungsverbot
verhängt werden das ist ehrlich gesagt
nichts anderes als ein arbeitsverbot die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht ist
meiner meinung nach nicht solidarisch
sondern asozial und muss weg ich habe
hier ein politiker am tisch der hat
dafür gestimmt um mich interessieren
jetzt erstmal die beweggründe für die
entscheidung damals die beweggründe
waren als ich sie einfach hier hat man
eine zeit in dem delta variante hatten
die durch deutschland wütete und ich
habe mich in dem moment klar von
abwägung entschieden wo der abel gruppen
zu schützen und da war für mich klar
dass ich zu dem zeitpunkt das auch genau
so abgestimmt habe wenn wir heute eine
million denken dann ist das eine andere
geschichte eine anderer verlauf der
korona des corona virus heute würde ich
das nicht mehr tun wenn der virus genau
so wäre wie er jetzt ist also das war
für mich eine entscheidung als
abgeordneter wo ich gesagt habe mein
gewissen hat mich einfach geleitet und
gesagt jawohl ich muss wohl gruppen
einfach schützen den krankenhäusern und
deswegen hab ich diese entscheidung
getroffen vollausbau im bewusstsein aber
ich war ja seit jahren zu nein sie haben
ja auch gegen die allgemeine impfpflicht
sich positioniert dadurch sei der
unterschied bei ihnen gegen eigenen
meine für einrichtungslösungen warum sie
haben selber gesagt der virus ist jetzt
ein anderer und wenn sie mal nicht in
die vergangenheit zu blicken warum
ändert die politik das jetzt nicht die
politik ändert reserve werden dass es
gehe jetzt in diesem monat noch anpassen
wir sind auch in einer koalition da muss
man gucken was möglich ist gar keine
frage und ich glaube auch da haben die
freien demokraten schon dazu beigetragen
dass wir sehr viel verantwortungsvoller
mit dieser ganzen situation umgehen
können ich glaube wir handelte auch sehr
verantwortungsvoll als freie demokraten
die menschen draußen bevölkerung für die
wünsche
wie lange wird es die einrichtungs
bezogen impfpflicht noch geben ja bis
ende des jahres war sie aus dem haus in
der koalition gibt es keine gespräche
darüber die allgemeine also die
einrichtungs betonen eigentlich zu
verlängern und das sei auch schon mal
eine gute nachricht haga frau wie sehen
sie das sollte es überhaupt noch bis
ende dezember gibt es eigentlich irgend
eine schnelle entscheidung seitens der
politik dass man das jetzt aufhebt also
ich bin natürlich für die sofortige
aufhebung damit bis heute niemand sagen
konnte wie wir also vielen corona
maßnahmen vielleicht hat es auch nur
gemacht worden damit herr lauterbach
noch einmal eine nacht ruhig
durchschlagen kann ohne panikanfall das
weiß nicht ob sie jetzt aber solche
therapeutischen maßnahmen in der
koalition auch besprochen werden denn
nur so kann ich mir das erklären bis
heute konnte ich mir die frage nicht
beantwortet werden also ich bin generell
gegen gesetzliche maßnahmen dieser art
da die freiheit ist einzeln für mich
über nahezu allen anderen stellt punkt
1.2
die meisten menschen die sich dem
entzogen haben oder die in der presse
aufgetreten sind auch aus meinem
bekanntenkreis sind selbst ärzte oder
pfleger oder schwestern niemand hat
bisher die frage wirklich beantworten
können warum aus grill eine berufsgruppe
die mit der krankheit unmittelbar
konfrontiert wurde im alltag nicht
einfach nicht berücksichtigt wurde
sondern sind zum teil eben entlassen
worden und dann klagt man über den
pflegenotstand da stimmt doch irgendwas
nicht ja und mir hat eine ärztin gesagt
den namen darf ich will ich nicht sagen
weil heutzutage ist es gefährlich seine
meinung zu sagen in deutschland aber die
frau die hier dürfen sie wird ja auch
das gibt der aufpasser die die noten
dateien aber
es ist ja so dass zum beispiel im
schäden die aufgetreten sind noch
impfung verdeckt wurden manipuliert
wurden und ärzte dies angemahnt haben
bestraft wurden abgemahnt wurden nur
soviel dazu also insofern halte ich das
für eine repressive maßnahmen wird druck
ausgeübt und nicht eine aus
gesundheitlichen gründen angemessene
klare antwort die holten sie haben haben
sie bekommen sehr klare antwort gegeben
arbeiter hier in die runde wie stehen
sie dazu ja also ich für mich ist kein
besonders großes problem ich denke mir
das muss ich auch kein pfleger ich bin
kein pfleger nicht aber aber die
motivation ist ja wirklich und diese
lauter besonders wilde gruppen zu
schützen und man braucht in einer klinik
kennen keinen kölner hotspot also denke
ich mir dass die überlegung durchaus
nachvollziehbar war und für mich gibt es
bereiche in der gesellschaft da müssen
sich die leute eben diesen regelungen da
werfen um an die einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht bin ich bin gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht warum sind sich
die einrichtungs bezogene daher auch
geimpfte geimpfte anstecken können also
es ist ja nicht so dass wenn jemand
geimpft ist er die variable patienten
nicht mehr anstecken kann da sich die
wissenschaftler eindeutig einige ja aber
es ist doch so dass sehen wir auch dass
leute geimpft sind der geringere eine
geringere wahrscheinlichkeit haben die
krankheit zu bekommen und das ist sicher
so schnell
auch nicht bewiesen dass
die
schulgründung
keine validen studien dazu
eine ungeimpfte pflegekraft gefährlicher
von den patienten glaubt man man kam
durch dadurch dass man dort geimpfte
leute hat das geschehen besser
kontrollieren entschuldigen sie ich habe
meine frage an sie können sie mir eine
klinik nennen der bundesrepublik
deutschland dieser zeit ein corona
hotspot ist nur zu zeigen dass sie keine
es gibt ja sie haben gerade gesagt dass
er verhindert dadurch dass es die
impfpflicht bitte bleiben sie doch
julian der diskussionsführung
ist er sehr
geschäftslage ein holzboden benennen
können nicht vielleicht morgen sollte
bitte ich habe gesagt man hat ihn
verhindert du nein sie haben versucht
ihn zu lesen in ordnung dann sind die
leute draußen haben die caps zuzuhören
und das tut frau ich habe es heute sogar
mal nachgeschaut die zahl und zwar
inwiefern die krankenhäuser krone
hotspot sind und aktuell sind drei
prozent der intensivbetten mit corona
patienten belegt es kann aber auch sein
dass sie was anderes habe und test haben
der positiven russells mittleren corona
das kann ja keiner bislang richtig
fertig sehen sie doch schon wieder blau
nummer aber die zahl 3 prozent ist ja
sehr sehr sehr gering selbst wenn man
die
ganze geschichte seiner von hinten bis
vorn ich bin kein großer leugner bin
auch keine sogenannter querdenker aber
ich bin glaube ich einen gut denker und
kann zahlen
kontakt wer denkt dass es hier heute ist
sie nein es ist ganz einfach so dass in
dem augenblick wo man eingeliefert wird
ist denn selbst leute die aufgeschoben
sind an herzversagen
und dann wurde carola auf den tod
entscheiden damit dazu geschrieben das
ist hier passiert über ihn als leading
das könnte ich ihnen belegen ich glaube
gar nichts mehr frau braunschweiger sie
sind ja masten gegnerin wenn man das so
sagen kann es steht im netz nein das
kann man so ein verkehrschaos
ja das hat mir genau wusste es sind
leute die
die sie für hier weiße unterwegs also
wurde ich angeklagt bereit sie angeblich
habe alles gewonnen die
beleidigungsklage ist vom tisch und ich
musste auch mein ansatz möchten sich in
zwei noch mal beschreiben das kann ich
schon machen also ich hab eine
grunderkrankung deswegen an masken r
-tests bin also befreit es gibt so
gewisse kräfte die das nicht so gerne
sehen die nicht akzeptieren können dass
es noch andere krankheiten auserkoren
ergebnis unglaublich harter so was schon
mal gehört aber okay gut es wird alles
getan menschen die nicht zu schikanieren
zu diskriminieren zu diffamieren als
rechts hinzustellen als sonst was
hinzustellen
ich habe dienstlich sogar probleme
bekommen ich finde dass das allerletzte
und unfassbar impertinent und in sohland
also unüberbietbar was haben sie für
probleme im recht da darf ich mich
leider nicht äußern ich habe allgemein
nicht die möglichkeit mich hier ist aus
dem fenster zu lehnen wie ihr alle
beneidenswerter weise lässt könnte weil
ich als bayerische beamtin des musicals
gebot habe die schweiz bringe ich
darf leider nicht fast nichts tun mir
sind die hände gebunden ich habe einen
maulkorb
ich finde es sehr schade nach manchen
sachen die ich hier schon gehört aber
vielleicht ist diese aussage auch
aussage genug ich mal
natürlich habe ich gewonnen weil ich den
polizisten nicht beleidigt habe das hat
er sich nur ausgedacht weil linke
feministinnen sowieso nicht leiden kann
und denen kann man schon mal eins
mitgeben wenn sich gerade anbietet das
hat er geschafft daher das finde ich
super herzliche grüße an dieser stelle
ich könnte mich jetzt noch darüber
aufregen wie man vielleicht mehr hat und
auch zurecht merkt vielleicht weil ich
versuche das mäßige uns gibt es in jeder
hinsicht aber ich fand hat schon
mitglied persönlich sehr verletzen wenn
man einen chronisch kranken menschen
schikaniert und diskriminiert und als
asozial hinstellt also das geht für mich
einfach nicht aber wie gesagt schon
gewonnen denn ärgert ich verstehe ärger
von bestimmten menschen natürlich mal
sie könnten auch keinem recht machen
halt staat also können nicht allen immer
alles recht machen jetzt erstmal eine
erste punkt der andere punkt ist sie
sagen das gepräge sie zu schikanieren
ich sage andersrum ist muss regeln geben
um auch menschen zu schützen vor einer
krankheit also wie gesagt wir sind nie
also ich bin noch nie unterwegs gewesen
dass ich gesagt habe ich glaube da nicht
dran dass das keine schweren verläufe
geben kann oder wie auch immer ich
glaube auch daran dass ich wenn ich
geimpft bin selbstverständlich geschützt
da bin vor einem schweren verlauf also
gar keine frage oder leidet davon dafür
würde sich vor meiner sicht lohnen ist
jedenfalls zu lassen nicht weißt ich
habe in meinem wenn ich mit dem
deutschen bundestag irgendwohin fliegen
muss da kriege ich impfung da frage ich
auch nicht was das für die impfstoffe
therapie da wird mir einfach gespritzt
und fertig weil sonst komme ich da gar
nicht rein in dieses land also
ich gehe nicht leicht werden hörbar um
das ist einfach der punkt wenn in
bestimmten ländern nicht einreisen will
gesagt wird du musst eine
gelbfieberimpfung haben dann habe ich es
gibt eben für eine gelbfieberimpfung
mitzubringen und nachzuweisen und welche
nicht habe da will ich ihnen eine frage
stellen die etwas provokantes ich gebe
es direkt schon mal zu dass eine
maßnahme sind ja nicht nur politiker sie
sind ja auch bürger ist eine maßnahme wo
sie heute sagen also die kann ich auch
nicht mehr verstehen die macht nicht
auch wahnsinnig ja also so ganz einfach
also beispielsweise die masken pflicht
im flugzeug oder im hergeschoben
aufgehoben aber naja an bleibt wie hat
die koalition also ich würde das
eine einigung gefunden koalition und das
dass das was ich daran persönlich nicht
verstehe wenn ich sage jetzt nicht als
fdp-politiker sowas bürger muss ich
sagen natürlich ärgert mich wenn ich im
pc immer zu nach hause per nach der
sitzung woche dass ich dort maske tragen
muss weil ich das denn nicht verstehe
warum darf ich das da und da nicht und
ja aber es ist halt auch im punkt wo ich
sage auch eine koalition ringt sich zur
entscheidung durch die sozusagen uns die
freiheit stück für stück wieder
zurückgeben und wir wollen sie an diesem
schritt nicht hindern und wenn man dann
die krücke findet über das europäische
gleichheitsgebot zu sagen in allen
fliegern ist die maske abgeschafft und
die kriege ich dann einfach abgeschafft
und freue ich mich darüber und dann
machen wir da sehen sie das ist der
grund warum ich froh bin der sina
koalition sind jp sie dürfen das nicht
mehr sagen
oder ist da drin sind menschwerdung
furchtbar eine gleichschaltung ist
nummer ist doch ganz klar dass sie ich
bin froh dass die freien demokraten da
sind ärgern sich oft über die besonderen
gerichts politischen fragen an
bestimmten teilen aber zumindestens das
haben sie in der korona sache bestanden